I'm Annie hollow and I said in plenty
for the lib dems and could you tell me
who you vote for Malaysian collection I
vote for Tim Farron here's one obviously
and that's why you're here tonight I
would have come with normal to one as
well but I did vote for Tamia how are
you feeling out the future of the lib
dems i cautiously optimistic I think
we're gonna do pretty well in to Tim and
then we reached rock bottom and he's got
charisma it's the kind of person that
can bring people back to us if anyone
can so cautiously optimistic like so and
I should confess at this point I work
for Greg Mulholland as who'd you vote
for in the leadership contest I were to
tell farah and why do you think you'll
make a good leader well Tim you know
it's got fantastic ability to engage
members you know he's travel up and down
the country over the last few weeks and
you know this is somewhat a solid
campaigner he's under nine to five years
of Tory hole to win his constituency
worn over half the vote even in this
difficult election we've just had so
he's a lot of camping that's what we
need at this time and that's how we're
going to rebuild a party what would you
like to see the party achieve over the
next five years I think yeah we want to
start to rebuild by a straight away from
Nexus local council elections and
summoner gaining more counselors and you
know start brewing a local base time for
more parliamentary success in twenties
mitad a Darryl Hamilton civil engineer I
when did you join the Liberal Democrat
about two months ago just after a
general election and who did you vote
for leadership contest
for Tim Farron and why do you think he's
gonna be the best man / leader because I
think you bring the liberal side of the
left lane and so back to the parity
they've gone to right wing in the past
couple of years and suddenly they had to
give in to some Tory demands for that
hopefully they'll take them back in
center of settler I'm worried and what
do you hope the lib dems to achieve over
the next five years I hope they did
build a party back from the grassroots
level and they listened to the air to
the membership ball across the country
and out hopefully they make a good push
for the next general election and their
every means to it going with Tory's
again or means go in labor and stop
either go left or right and so big you
know but hopefully they can make some
gains the next comfort acosta Events
Manager and who did you vote for in the
leadership contest i voted for Norman
lamb and you're here to celebrate in
Tallinn I'm here to celebrate our new
leader yes and how are you feeling about
10 pounds victory I think it's a very
exciting time for the party the election
showed that it is a great chance for a
party to move forward I may have not
voted for Tim himself but I believe that
he is that he is going to be an
excellent leader for the party to bring
us forward to lead the party and engage
the new members we've had such an
upsurge of new memberships since Nick
Clegg resign but I think it's a great
opportunity to get them engaged and to
show the country what a liberal Britain
is actually like